[Music]
so have you grown to like the Grateful
Dead and drugs and was that on the same
day alright cuz you would repel you
didn't listen to that you listen to like
I brought home eazy-e when I was 14 know
in person but the cassette tape oh my
god it would have been cooler if you
brought I bronze Tupac to my dad's house
when I was like 16 the man the man not
yet tape not the tape you brought to us
he was a friend of a friend we were
partying at my dad's house and my dad
was on the road and that was really part
of my early rebellion yep he was like
the only friend of mine in you know like
1990 who even had any reverence for my
dad or more appreciation of him yeah
that's great yeah it's not trippy
everything's an illusion do you do you
believe it
is the world of veil it's complicated
like I'm still trying to figure it out
right at the end of the day like do you
want to be bummed or do you want to be
happy what depends on what thought
you're holding in your little peanut up
there thank you so much Dixie this was
amazing we should close with our
signature move Thank You class bet
[Music]